hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
car t-cell immunotherapy of solid tumors
learning from the clinic and lab in
parallel
i'm alexis krauss of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labberts and sponsored
by lumix
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at lumix.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions
as you want at any time you want during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left ear screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
dr john mayer
clinical immunologist scientific founder
and chief scientist
scientific officer at lucid bio and dr
rohir reimers
principal scientist at lumix for the
complete biographies on our presenters
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr reimers you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone welcome to this joint
webinar
my name is rohi reimers and i'm the
principal scientist of
lumix in my part we'll cover how using
lumix z multi can help in selecting the
best car lead candidates
for immunotherapy by determining an
additional important parameter
that is cellular avidity which reflects
the binding strength between t cells and
target cells
but first shortly i would like to
introduce lumix lumix was founded in
2014
and has its headquarters stationed in
amsterdam the netherlands
over the last six years we've grown from
a small startup company with only two
employees
to a scale-up that is currently joined
by almost 120 gifted people
from all over the world bluemix develops
instruments for scientific research
and in april of this year we launched
our newest product
the zmo fee cell ability analyzer which
is available for sale
the multi quantifies cellular binding
ability
directly and in a high throughput manner
at a single cell level
and in the second part of this webinar
we will show that avidity has predicted
value for car
t cell functionality the zmulvi avidity
measurements are reproducible because
avidity is measured using a biophysical
method
and it's also that the movie is fast you
can obtain your ability results of
hundreds
of interacting cell pairs within minutes
and of course but why did we develop
this technology why
why are these features important
and we think that it can accelerate the
identification of
lead candidates
as great successes have been achieved
adopted cell therapy
still has its implementations and
drawbacks most importantly
optimal pre-clinical design including
car engineering are a work in progress
and
still require refinement in many
patients
treatment with car t cells responders
develop cytokine release syndrome
often in combination with neurotoxicity
which when left untreated can be fatal
to the patient
and another major issue is the fact that
car t cells
mostly fail when applied to solid tumors
however when targeting tumors with less
specific markers
unlike v-cell malignancies there is a
high likelihood of
on target of tumor toxicity which could
be fatal to patients as well
as a result lead candidates could fill
clinical trials
for this reason many clever approaches
have been developed by applying complex
engineering to
car expressing t cells that could result
in more specific therapies
with reduced of tumor toxicity but also
minimizing t cell exhaustion these
include for example
targeted insertion of a car into the tcr
locus
which lead to a more physiological
expression pattern
and reduced exhaustion or making use of
dual cars that recognize
two targets which is required for
activation
thereby reducing of tumor toxicity
and finally a strategy that could lead
to reduced of tumor effects
is affinity tuning of existing cars that
otherwise
easily recognize healthy tissue
expressing low levels of tumor targets
or increase the efficacy of car t cells
something
that was recently shown for smc 63
a well-known cd19 car
here two cars fm 63
and cat which has been derived from fm
fmc 63 will compare they both started
the same epitope of cd19
but with a very important difference the
affinity
for cd19 of cats is 40 fold lower
what you can see here is very
interesting as the low affinity catgar
performs better in terms of tumor
self-healing in vitro
at every ect ratio explored in this
study
when the same two cars were compared in
an in vivo
pre-clinical mouse model you can see a
similar pattern
where the high affinity car is only
capable of slowing down the tumor
compared to the control but the low
affinity cat car
can reduce the tumor burden very
significantly
these data show that having a high
affinity car
will not per se result in the best
t-cell function
so a fair question to ask is do we have
the right tools in place to efficiently
select the best lead candidates
in essence the traditional biophysical
methods primarily focus
on affinity for car lead selection
generally known
as the strength of interaction between
one ligand and one receptor
this type of interaction completely
neglects the biological complexity
that is inherently linked to cell
function and therefore
what is missing is the cellular ability
that can be described as the overall
strength of interactions between a
diversity of receptor ligand pairs
at the cell cell interface as shown in
this in this figure below
for a star t cell interacting with a
tumor target
not only is the car binding to the
target also many other interactions
must be considered which for example
includes
adhesion or co-stimulatory molecules
to be able to measure such interactions
there is a need
for technology that allows direct fast
and high throughput measurements of
t-cell binding avidity
and for this this reason we have
developed the z-movie cell ability
analyzer at lumix
because it is becoming more and more
clear that the anti-tumor response is
really driven
by the overall collection of
interactions that take place between the
t-cell
and the tumor cell it is the t-cell
binding ability that drives tumor
killing
through the formation of a strong and
mature immunological sinus
in this specific sinus state the
interaction forces
substantially increase because of the
active recruitment of many adhesion
molecules
at the cell cell interface and only
in this state the t cells can execute
the killing
by very locally delivering cytotoxic
molecules
the multi can measure the binding
strength at the most critical stage of
this process
where the sinus is forming how does
the molphy measure this cellular ability
the demog relies on a small microfluidic
lap on the chip shown at the top of this
slide target cells are seated on the
bottom
of the glass surface and t cells are
co-cultured on the top of the monolayer
the flow cell is 100 micrometers in
height and the piezo element
in yellow on top can generate standing
waves in the flow cell medium
these standing waves can be compared to
sound waves coming from your radio
speaker
if the magnitude of the force exceeds
the binding strength of the cell pairs
the t cells will be lifted into an
acoustic nodes
which can be considered a zero gravity
area where cells float until the piezo
element is switched off
in this way the movie makes use of
acoustic forces to separate cells
and the magnitude of force that is
needed to separate these interacting
cells
is a direct readout for their ability
let me show you a movie of how this
looks like when you run a real
experiment here you see
fluorescently dyed t cells
on a monolayer in black when you
start the acoustic force you can see
that
the cells accumulate in the acoustic
nodes
and in this field of view you can
measure the ability of up to
three to four hundred cells in one go
so how do you get to a run like this
you see a simplified overview of the
workflow so let's go a bit into more
detail
first you select your target cells which
could be a panel of cells expressing
different level of engine typically one
uses
100 million cells per ml in a maximum
volume
of 50 microliters which is needed for
one run
with a maximum of five runs per reusable
chip
then you flush in the target cells and
see the chip to generate a monolayer
the incubation time on average is about
2 hours
preparation time for an avidity essay
will be no longer than 30 minutes
then you prepare your control or
engineer
t cells and dye them with a reflection
dye
for tracking as shown in the movie on
the previous slide
t cells are used at a concentration of
10 million cells per ml
and you need only 30 microliters per run
preparation time for an avidity assay
generally is about one hour
and finally you incubate the t cells
with target cells which takes about five
minutes
which is the time that they are allowed
to format synapse
but this is flexible you can start the
acoustic fourth ramp
which is standardized to a two and a
half minute fourth ramp going from zero
to a thousand piconewton but this is
flexible as well
you could also use a static force or go
even higher
although that could affect the quality
of the monolayer
after the fourth ramp you wash away the
t cells
and incubate your next key cell
population up to 5 runs
all together when incubation time is set
to five minutes
five sequential runs will be will take
about one hour of experimental time
this will lead in the following figures
here you see an example of ability
curves that can be obtained after an
experiment
the curves depict the percentage of
bound t cells to the monolayer as a
function of force
based on a negative control a background
binding gate can be set
which usually coincides with the moment
the negative control cells no longer
display
a detachment event
this gate determines the minimum force
that is required
to release all non-binding t cells this
gate then determines the percentage of t
cells that specifically bind to the
target monolayer
which can be shown in a bar graph it
reflects the percentage
within your t-cell pool that
specifically interacts with dark model
layer
compared to the negative control and
these t-cells require
an additional increase in force to break
the specific bonds
one has to realize that the avidity
curve consists
of individual events of single p-cells
that detach
from the monolayer each having their own
specific force this can be plotted as a
violin dot block
these are the type of graphs that we use
to show our data generated with the
z-movie
as proof of principle i'm showing you a
data set
that was collected by professor steven
belda one of our collaborators at uben
who is doing research on car t cells
targeting lung cancer
what you see are two cars that start the
same engine
but they revealed different levels of
infitrocytotoxicity
either high or low in the presence of
high antigen expressing tumor cells
you immediately see that the humidity
curve of the high functioning car
in red is higher compared to the low
functioning car
in yellow which both have a much higher
ability than the background controls
in black when you zoom in at the
specific acoustic force of 250
piconewton
which is the background gate you see
that the high-functioning car t-cell
population has a far
greater percentage of specific binders
than the low functioning car
one may ask whether this behavior is
dependent on the presence of a specific
engine
and what might happen when the engine is
not expressed by the dark cells
as such when measuring avidity in the
absence
of the target engine on the monolayer
none of the t-cell populations bind
diesel binding avidity is very low in
all three cases tested
and only background binding is observed
this technology has also been used by
our next presenter
dr john maher he will explain
how he identified the most potent car
amongst his affinity tuned panel
using t-movie which resulted in the best
performing car
in a novel configuration that he
developed known as
parallel car t-cells i'm excited to hear
about the latest development
and i'm looking forward to his
presentation please john
the virtual floor is yours
well hello everybody and my name is john
maher i'm the chief scientific officer
of uh
lucid bio and it's it's a pleasure to
present at this
webinar hosted by lumix today
and i guess my presentation today is
going to be
the proverbial game of two halves
initially i'm going to tell you a little
bit about a clinical trial
that we have running involving a car t
product here in london at
guys hospital and then i'll describe
some pre-clinical
research that we have been conducting
developing a
next-generation car technology which we
refer to as a parallel car
and i'll tell you a little bit about how
we use lumix
as that movie technology to enable us to
select
targeting moistures or binders which
proved useful
in this work and this slide shows
um my disclosures
so the clinical trial that i'd like to
tell you about involves
a product that we refer to as t4
immunotherapy
and t4 immunotherapy involves the
co-expression
of two chimeric receptors in patient
derived t
cells the first of these is a second
generation car shown on the top of this
cartoon
which we refer to as tie 28 zeta
so the signaling components within tai
28 zeta
are by now pretty standard it's a fusion
of cd28
with cd3 zeta providing signal one and
signal two
to activate these t cells what's a
little unusual about
this car is the targeting moiety which
is not
an antibody fragment but instead is a
chimeric polypeptide known as t1e
and the t1e polypeptide is in fact a
promiscuous herb b
ligand it can engage eight different
herb b homo or heterodimers
and therefore provides very broad
targeting specificity
for epithelial malignancies
now we're co-expressing thai 28 data
with a chimeric cytokine receptor that
we developed many years ago
called four alpha beta and this
essentially
harnesses the very poorly mitogenic
cytokine
interleukin-4 to deliver a selective
potent growth signal only to the car t
cells
so it provides a convenient system to
enable us to selectively
expand our transduced t cells during our
two-week
manufacturing process
now thus targeting the extended herb b
network
offers a lot of potential in terms of
treating
solid tumors it obviously also confers
a potential safety risk because of
course these dimers are also
expressed at lower levels in many
healthy tissues
throughout the body and it was for this
reason that we selected
head and neck squamous cell carcinoma
as our target disease because we viewed
this
as a disease model in which we could
evaluate the safety
and potential efficacy of infra-tumoral
delivery
of car t cells the main clinical problem
that these patients encounter is shown
by this rather graphic
image here in other words locally
advanced or locally recurrent
tumor formation we also selected head
and neck cancer because
this is a tumor which highly expresses
the target
these tumors are virtually ubiquitously
positive
for egfr and tumor cells generally
co-express at least one of the other or
b family members
it's a cancer against which we haven't
really made a great deal of progress in
terms
of five-year survival in recent years
and it's still stuck at more or less 50
percent in these patients
another key reason that we selected this
malignancy
relates to the prognosis for patients
once their clinician explains to them
that there is no
suitable conventional treatment for
their disease
these are this kaplan-mara curve was
generated from data
generated at our cancer center at guys
hospital and what you see is that
these untreatable patients begin to die
of their disease
literally from day one and by 30 weeks
after receiving such a prognosis all of
these patients will have died of their
disease
so for this reason we viewed this um
this clinical
scenario as a kind of an ethically
justifiable
area for the delivery of this
potentially toxic
infra-tumoral car t cell approach
the design of our clinical trial is
relatively conventional
by phase one or first in man new cancer
medicine
clinical studies so it's a dose
escalation
three plus three study in which the
first cohort of patients receive a dose
of 10 million car t
cells which are injected as a fresh
product at a single setting injecting
multiple points around the viable
periphery
of the target lesion and we escalate
through five different dose levels
up to a maximum deliverable dose of one
billion car t cells
more recently we have opened the sixth
cohort in which we have
reduced the dose of car t cells to ten
to the eight cells
but these car t cells are administered
after lympho-depleting chemotherapy
with the combination of flu darubine and
cyclophosphamide being a first in man
study it's primarily about safety
but we have a number of secondary
endpoints translational endpoints
which are designed to inform us about um
the mechanisms and the persistence of
these t
cells at the site of injection
this is a rather busy slide which shows
the characteristics of the 18 patients
who have been
recruited to date to this clinical study
you will see that two of the patients
were not treated
patient number five unfortunately died
of his disease
during the two-week period that we were
manufacturing the car t
cells and we had another patient patient
number 12
who by the time he presented to our
center had vascular
invasive disease which is an exclusion
criterion and therefore we were unable
to treat that patient
all of the other 16 patients were
treated
with car t cells at the target dose
and without any manufacturing failures
over the course of the study to date
manufacturer um of t4 immunotherapy
benefits
from the il4 based expansion system that
i alluded to earlier
and this has made our lives a lot
simpler in fact because it means that we
can make these car t
cells from a blood draw rather than from
a leukopheresis
in fact we aim to take 120 milliliters
of blood from patients
although on one occasion we only
received 40 ml of blood
but nonetheless these relatively modest
volumes of blood
are sufficient for the robust
manufacture
of a car t cell product containing
between two and a half
and seven and a half billion car t cells
the right of this slide shows the
percentage of transduct
transduced cells present in these
products at the midpoint
and on the final day of manufacture and
you can see this
upward um trajectory of the proportion
of transduced cells over this period
reflecting the selective advantage that
il4
confers to the transduced cells during
this
manufacturing process
so far i'm pleased to say that t4
immunotherapy has proven to be safe
following intra-tumoral delivery of
these
freshly formulated car t cells
we have not seen dose-limiting
toxicities in any of the patients
treated with doses of up to one billion
car t
cells that's not to say that t4
immunotherapy
is free of side effects we commonly see
that the target lesion becomes inflamed
and swollen
following the infra tumor delivery of
these cells and that process can persist
for days or sometimes even weeks
and in some cases has been treated with
um systemic oral corticosteroids
but what we have not seen is any
evidence of significant leakage of car t
cells out of the tumor site and into the
peripheral blood and for this reason
uh we have not seen dose limiting
toxicities
or indeed on target of tumor toxicity in
these patients
one of the questions that we're commonly
asked is about persistence of car t
cells in these tumors this is quite a
difficult question to address
although we do have paired tumor
biopsies from a subset of the patients
and in some cases we have seen
detectable signal
present at a week or two weeks post
administration of car t cells
from an efficacy perspective thus far
of the 16 treated patients 10 of these
patients have achieved stable disease by
rhesis at six weeks post-treatment
i think this is encouraging because of
the fact that these patients
when they receive no treatment have
rapidly progressed the tumors at this
phase of the disease
and as i have explained earlier all of
these patients
will die of their disease within 30
weeks
this is the kaplan-meier curve which is
based upon
intention to treat analysis and
demonstrates the fact that the patients
treated
in this trial appear to survive for
longer
the black arrow on the x-axis of this
survival curve
indicates the time point at which all
historical controls
will have died of their disease and we
did have one patient
who did very well following t4
immunotherapy
a man who received 10 to the eighth car
t cells he achieved stable disease
by racist and then went on to receive
pembrolizumab and tivek
in a second clinical trial he went into
complete remission
following this second intervention and
that remission
has been durable to this day a period of
over three years
the other secondary endpoint that we
have been exploring
in this study has been the migration of
the car t cells
from the target lesion i've already
mentioned that
using either qpcr or flow cytometry we
have not been able to detect any
systemic leakage of car t cells in one
patient we have also labeled up a very
small number of the car t
cells with indium and we have conducted
spec
ct imaging and what you can see
interestingly is that
at the time of injection or indeed 24
hours later
there is clear signal present at the
target site
but by a further 24 hours later you can
see that these cells have migrated
across the oral cavity
to a site at which no macroscopically
evident disease
was present we think this represents
um migration of the car t cells through
the highly disrupted lymphatic
drainage of that tumor
so at this point i'm going to change
tack and move from the clinic back into
the lab
to tell you about a technology which we
are developing through lucid bio and
which we refer to
as a parallel car this builds upon the
fact that we have seen
various functions of cars over the years
which involve the
operational incarceration modules to
classify the signal provided by the data
chain within the car
second generation cars which contain
either cd 28 or 401 vb
have proven to be highly effective in
the context of hematological
malignancies
reflecting the importance of
co-stimulation in the success of this
technology
but perhaps somewhat surprisingly
third-generation
cars in which these co-stem domains are
arranged linearly
have not really impacted in any kind of
meaningful way
over and above what we have seen with
the second generate generation precursor
and that led us to speculate that
perhaps the
third generation technology is not
properly enabled
because the two co-stimulatory domains
are not
in physical proximity to the plasma
membrane of the t-cell
in the p-car system what we have done is
to separate out these two co-stimulatory
modules
on two separate chimeric receptors so in
other words
what we are doing is co-expressing a
second generation
car alongside a chimeric co-stimulatory
receptor
which contains a distinct co-stimulatory
module
the first system in which we tested the
p-car approach
involved chimeric receptors which were
targeted against
colony stimulating factor one receptor
and this is a rather busy slide here
but essentially what we have done here
is to perform re-stimulation
experiments in which we iteratively
re-expose
the car t cells for fresh tumor modeler
which expresses csf1 or and what we
found was that with
second or third generation cars these
all behaved in more or less a similar
um manner enabling re-stimulation
through
two three four sometimes five cycles
if we co-expressed a first-generation
car with a dual chimeric co-stimulatory
receptor
placing cd28 upstream of 401 bb
we did not see any advantage with that
arrangement
however the bottom of the slide shows
three parallel car systems
in which we co-express cd28 with either
41 bb
aux 40 or cd27 using this parallel
configuration
and as you can see in all cases we can
restimulate these the
t cells through more cycles
and when we move that p car technology
in vivo in a lymphoma model which
expresses very low levels
of the target antigen we see that while
third generation cars have
no therapeutic impact in this system the
p
car can eradicate the tumor in three out
of nine mice
and delayed tumor progression into
further
animals having
demonstrated that proof of concept with
the csf1r system
we then moved to the most clinically
validated target
antigen which of course in the context
of car t
is cd19 and we have as we have heard
from the earlier presentation
by roger and we know that the affinity
of a
the targeting moiety in the context of
cd19 car t immunotherapy
appears to be important to maximize not
only efficacy but also to get the right
balance from a safety perspective so
conscious of this what we did was we
took
the fmc 63 single chain antibody
fragment
and we mutagenized that to generate a
panel of mutants
we ranked these mutants in the context
of the 28 zeta
second generation car using the zed
movie technology
so the f2 car shown in black here
represents
a standard 28 zeta car
in which the targeting moiety is
unmodified
fmc 63 and you can see the binding curve
generated using the zed movie platform
indicated by the black line
and indicating that the avidity of these
car t
cells is quite high some of the mutants
such as mutant number one have no
detectable
binding ability in the assay performing
similarly to untransduced t
cells whereas other mutants
perform in a kind of intermediate way
and what was
interesting for us to learn was that the
two binders in the middle which i had
labeled as the
goldilocks binders were the ones which
ultimately generated
the best cars and the best parallel cars
when assessed from a functional
perspective
this is another example of the kind of
data output generated using the zed
movie system
this is a single run from a single boner
in which we are plotting
the dislodgement of individual cells
against the force required to achieve
that and what you can see is that many
of the cells are dislodged in the early
phase but you see this
tail of cells which bind more tightly
and which allows the discrimination
between
the different mutagenized single chain
antibodies which were used
in this uh series of work
you can also plot the data as an avidity
score where the ability of the
untransduced t
cells is set to one and once again you
see this
pecking order of binding ability of
these various
cars and another way to present the data
is shown here
this plots the minimal force required to
dispatch 90
of the untransduced t cells and you can
see that you
dislodge relatively fewer of the cd19
specific car t
cells but again there is a ranking order
which emerges
in these studies moving that on to
function
what you see here is an in vivoxenograph
study using the
well-established non-six leukemic model
where if we treat these mice with pbs
you can see rapid progression of the
leukemia
if we treat with a relatively low dose
of car t cells
labeled as f2 where the fmc 63
single chain antibody fragment is
unmodified you see a degree of
delay of progression of that leukemic
burden
the in-house generated cars are numbered
on the top
2 4 and 5 and in each case there is a
further delay in leukemic progression
and when we convert those cars into a
corresponding p-car
again we see a further delay in disease
progression
as a result of which we see a
significant prolongation of survival
particularly with the p-car engineered
t-cells
here's another example of the p-car
technology
targeted against the mach 1 museum many
years ago we found that mach 1 was a
particularly difficult
target to engineer traditional linear
cars against
largely because of the steric hindrance
imposed by this mucin
but what we find if you look at the
killing assays on the top of this slide
is that when you move to the p-car
system you see
a shift in the dose response curve
indicated by the transition from
orange over to green in these curves
on the bottom left you see um pooled
re-stimulation
assays similar to those i described with
the csf1 or system
and you can see that these p-car t cells
on average
can be re-stimulated through more cycles
on fresh tumor modular
in the absence of cytokine support the
bottom right
is a xenograft experiment it's a triple
negative
breast cancer xenograft 468 cells which
express mach 1
and you can see that the second
generation car shown by orange
has virtually no therapeutic activity in
this model
whereas the p car shown by green and can
control this
established tuner burden another example
builds upon the t4 car that i alluded to
in the
beginning of this presentation it was
natural for us to make
a p car derivative and when we compare
the function of the 2g
car or the p car in vitro we see
a perhaps a small advantage in favor of
the p-corp
both in terms of cytotoxic activity
shown on the left
and cytokine production shown on the
right of this slide
when we then move this in vivo into a
head and neck
tumor xenograph model what we found was
that both
the second generation car shown in
purple
and the p car shown in red could
completely eradicate this established
head and neck tumor burden but by day 63
in the tumor free mice we were able to
conduct a tumor
re-challenge and we could now see clear
blue water
between the 2g car treated mice in which
a smoldering tumor burden was
established and the p-car treated mice
in which this tumor re-challenge was
rejected
another example showing the same
principle with cars and p
cars targeted against the alpha v beta6
integrin
this is a challenging xenograph model
based on bx pc3
pancreatic tumor cells they express
alpha b
b to six integrin but with a 2g car you
really only make a dent in this tumor
before you see rapid
tumor relapse with a p-car derivative by
contrast
you can eradicate the tumor in three out
of five mice with
delayed tumor progression in a fourth
animal
nkd2d ligands are another
fertile group of targets for them the
p-car
system because they're very widely
expressed in many solid tumors
and some hemological malignancies again
you see a similar principle
summarized in this slide whereby these
nkg 2d
picard t cells can be re-stimulated
on tumor monolayers through many more
cycles than
conventional cars or control t cells
and when we test the function of these
cells in a three-dimensional spheroidal
model of pancreatic cancer
in which we co-express tumor shown in
green
and tumor associated stroma shown in red
you can see that the p-car can
completely disrupt
those tumor steroids but we do not see
this with
any of the controls when we move this
system
in vivo against that bx pc3
pancreatic tumor model what we see is
that
either a low or a high dose of these p
car t cells
we see tumor eradication in the majority
of the mice
and what i think is telling about this
model is that
on the top you can see in blue and red
two examples
of t4 car t cell immunotherapy of this
model
even though herb dimers are expressed by
this bx pc3 xenograft
you can see that these car t cells have
very limited anti-tumor activity
reflecting the refractory nature of this
xenograft model
and in fact we were able to re-challenge
tumor-free mice
in this experiment and four out of five
mice
which were re-challenged in this manner
rejected
that second injection of bxpc3
tumor cells leading in turn to a
survival advantage for these
treated mice so i will
end on that note there are many people
to to thank
across both the clinical uh trial that i
described and also the p-car technology
i'll mention mark davies who played an
instrumental role in the early
development of t4
and also nkg tdp cars i'll also mention
sophie papa
who has been who's a medical oncologist
who has been helping me to deliver the
clinical trial that i described and also
all of my colleagues at lucid bio
who are developing the pcar system
thank you all for your attention thanks
once again to lumix for the invitation
to present today and i look forward to
receiving your questions
thank you
thank you dr reimers and dr mayer for
your informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
um looks like it's going to be for dr
reimers
um could you use other effector cells
other than t cells instead
um yeah thank you um that's a good
question
the system is actually uh generated to
to measure
uh uh interaction strength between any
cell
so you can you can uh see your
target cells on on the glass surface and
then
come back with your secondary cells and
we have
used t cells but also in gay cells
[Music]
t cells with biospecifics um and also in
the past we've been using
b-cells for example but it's also
possible um
to turn it around and then you can seat
your effector cells for example
and come in uh with your target cells so
um
yes there is more than t cells only
thank you
wonderful um our next question uh we're
going to scooch on over to you dr mayer
do you know how long car t cells persist
in the tumor
after injection of t4 immunotherapy
yeah thanks alexis i mean this is a
question we're always asked it's
a really important question and of
course it's a very difficult question to
actually assess in practice
and so i touched on some of the things
that we have tried to do
to begin to address this question in the
presentation so we have taken paired
biopsy
from a subset of patients i think three
patients in total
and the one of the challenges you face
with
biopsies from these kind of tumors
particularly following treatment
is that the quality of the biopsy is
often
somewhat compromised perhaps because of
the inflammatory
response to the treatment and of course
the propensity for
sampling error etc but but we have
designed an rna scope probe
uh to enable us to search for car t
cells and i think we have seen some
evidence of persistence of car t cells
at one to two weeks out post treatment
in some of those biopsies
i guess there are also clinical pointers
to persistence of car t
cells in these target sites for a matter
of weeks
because generally the the patients who
receive infra tumor card
cells develop quite a pronounced local
inflammatory
reaction which really begins within 12
to 24 hours of injection
of the t cells and in some cases this
has persisted for weeks
and one or two of the patients have
received corticosteroids because the
reaction was uncomfortable for them and
that generally
abrogates or reduces the the local
inflammatory reaction
but in some cases when the steroids are
stopped we see these target sites
beginning to become inflamed
once again suggesting that the cells do
persist
for for a matter of weeks
great thank you so much for that answer
um our next question
is how do you avoid t-cell attachment
onto the glass in the z movie
yes uh thank you for that question it's
a it's a
good and relevant question um
so first of all we tried we have our
protocols optimized
to have a confluent layer
of target cells on the glass surface
which usually
surpasses 90 percent but obviously there
is
some bear glass still present so our
software can detect
uh t cells that attach to the glass
um and we also block the glass surface
so we use uh
serum for that so the t cells although
not measured
will directly lift off when lift off
when the force is
induced so um they do not really bind
and the software does not recognize them
or it does recognize them but it
excludes them from the analysis
great now moving on to our next question
do you think there is a standard optimal
ability
for car t cells or is this likely to
vary
depending on target antigen
that's a very interesting question from
dr wilding
and it's very difficult to be
categorical at this stage because our
experience with the
zed movie technology amounts to a single
um
target antigen and set of cars so i
think we'll probably need to acquire
more data with other antigens before
being able to
definitively respond to that question
however my
instinct is that it's probably going to
turn out to be a case of
requiring precise optimization of
avidity for individual targets
given all of the complexities associated
with the different targets that we look
at
such as for example their distance the
distance of the target epidote
from the the tumor cell membrane its
accessibility
its propensity to post-translational
modification
glycosylation etc etc so i suspect it's
going to be a case
of working worth optimizing for
an individual target antigens
now does more than one car t cell engage
a single target cell on the slide
um yeah that's a that's a good question
um so
usually with with the standard essays
like cytokine release
or cytotoxicity it's very important to
have the right
e to t ratio to to measure effector
functions
um with the z-movie we actually
have tuned the protocol in such a way
that we have low e to t ratio
but that is not very important because
uh the measurements are at the very
beginning
of uh of of the efficacy of t cells
which is
binding to the target the recognition of
the target information of the immune
synapse
so um because of that
we actually never see uh two star two uh
car t cells uh attached to a one target
cell
uh so that and and besides that um
if you see that you the the the software
package allows you
to deselect these cells if you're not
interested in these cells
so this gives you some freedom as well
so thank you for the question great so
we
we do have time for a couple uh a couple
more questions these are some great
questions from the audience so thank you
so much for those i do want to remind
that these
any questions that we are unable to
answer today and those that come in
during our on-demand period
will be answered by the speakers via the
email address that you provide
at the time of registration so dr mayor
this next one is for you
do you have any evidence that dual
co-stimulation is delivered by the
parallel car system
yes i mean that's an interesting
question and
and i guess cool stimulation by cd 28
is relatively straightforward to to
measure at a functional level because
you can look at things like
interleukin-2
production proliferation of car t-cells
etc and we do clearly see that with the
p-car system because simulation by the
tnf ores can be a little bit more
challenging
to uncover but one of the readouts that
we've been
interested in looking at has been nf
kappa b
activation so we have sam carried out
some experiments with
a reporter cell line an nf kappab
reporter cell line
and what we see is that with 401 bb
containing second
generation cars that we get a nice
signal with
that reporter system as we might expect
but when we move to a third generation
car in which cd28 is placed
upstream of 401 db the signal is
somewhat diminished suggesting that the
functionality
of the 401 bb unit within that linear
endo domain is compromised whether it be
because of the geography of the car e.g
the
costing domain is too far away from the
plasma membrane
or whether it be perhaps because of
steric factors whereby the two coasting
domains
prevent each other from working properly
when we use the same system to evaluate
p-car
and the p-car system we see a stronger
uh if anything for nf-kappab
reporter signal that is seen even with
the 401 vb containing second generation
car so i would say that's the primary
indicator that we have obtained
of tnf or co-stimulation using that
system
maybe one other final comment on that
subject
and i mean there have been quite a
number of mechanistic studies carried
out in recent years comparing
co-stimulation by 401 vb and cb28
containing second generation cars
and it's interesting actually if you
look at phospho-proteomic
analysis for example it seems to me that
there are more similarities than
differences between the two so it's
probably quite difficult to unpick
to a degree and these kind of nuances in
terms of the quality of stimulation that
you're delivering
but um we have carried out gene
expression analysis using nanostring and
one of the hits
that was pretty clear in favor of the
p-car system
was a stronger cytokine signal upon
initial stimulation of the p-car
with and cognace antigen so i think
that's possibly another
indicator that we are seeing firing of
both co-simulatory units
uh together uh via the p-car system
great thank you so much for that answer
dr mayor so our next question
does the z movie also work with
molecular
or excuse me with modular car t cells
that engage in adapter molecule
for example cd16 car t cells that bind
antibodies
that's that's a very nice and
interesting question
um so the short answer is yes
the somewhat longer answer is that
z-movie allows
any type of cell cell interaction be it
with
just normal uh receptor ligand
interaction
or by a module a modular car
t or or with antibodies so we also
have performed exp experiments with a
collaborator
working with biospecific antibodies and
there you can also very nicely see that
if you use the specific
t-cell engager that acts on cd3 and its
target
compared to negative control very nicely
has a very high
avidity curve compared to the negative
controls so as long as you are looking
at a cell cell-induced interaction
the z-movie can measure these type of
interaction strengths
so our next question there are a couple
parts to this question
so for introducing the p cars is it a
single vector or
co-transduction and how many cars can
you put into one t
cell and the last part of this have you
tried
non-viral methods
okay well very nice series of questions
there from dr kloss
and regarding the first question so we
we use a single vector
and i mean nowadays it's pretty
straightforward
to co-express two or three trans genes
using ribosomal skin peptides
from a single retro or lentiviral vector
once you get beyond that point it starts
to become a little bit of a struggle
but the p-car requires the co-expression
of two different chimeric receptors so
that's
straightforward in some of the work
we've carried out
on the p-car platform we have also
co-expressed the four alphabet
chimeric cytokine receptor meaning that
we have three
trans genes that were co-expressing and
that has also not been
um problematic and the second
uh part of the question how many cars
can you put into one t-shirt well i
possibly covered that in the comments
that i've just made
so i would say three up to three
transgene
and tr expression of three trans genes
using a pretty standard
retro or antiviral vector is feasible
beyond that limit
you're beginning to struggle um have
we tried non-viral methods i think the
short answer there is no
although i would be very interested
actually because i'm
i am impressed by some of the data which
is beginning to emerge
using a number of non-viral methods uh
transposes
etc and both in terms of transgene
expression
state of differentiation of t cells and
i think that's possibly go and also cost
of goods of course
and i think that's possibly going to
translate in the clinic in the not
too distant future and so so i would
certainly be interested in trying
non-viral methods although i've been a
bit of a dinosaur over the years
and sticking to our retro retroviral
system
wonderful so it looks like we've got
time for maybe two more questions for
our speakers today
uh our next one is it possible to pick
the interacting car t
cells for further analysis
uh yeah thank you for uh for that
question um
this this really shows that i've
explained the technology well
because indeed uh and also as john
uh actually showed uh each uh
t cell that detaches from uh from the
target cell
has its own interaction force um
and yeah that means that the t-cell
batch that you use
displays a large variety in
interaction strength and perhaps there
is a
c t-cell population within your batch
that can be highly interesting
and for that of course it would be very
interesting to sort these cells
for now uh we have our first generation
z-movie analyzer on the markets so
this does not allow for uh cell sorting
so far uh it is a project that we
have kicked off actually um and that we
would like to develop in the next two
years
uh which will allow you to sort the
cells
after they detach from from the
monolayer
so um yeah interesting question and uh
something that we are pursuing with
bluemix thank you
wonderful and it looks like we've got
time for our last question
and we'll scooch back on over to dr
mayer
what are your plans for clinical
development of the p-car system
that's again a very interesting question
and
quite a few ideas really spring to mind
and
i guess the best validated target in
in car t at the moment is cd19
and i have shown you some data on the
panel of cd19p
cars that we have developed through
lucid and so we would be very interested
in evaluating a cd19
peak car in the clinic perhaps in in the
refractory
lymphoma setting so that's plan number
one i guess
and similarly in terms of the other mp
cars that i described
with potential application in the
context of solid tumors
i guess i'm particularly excited about
the nkg 2d
targeted parallel car systems and
given the the fact that these ligands
are a marker of stress
cells and of course tumor cells are a
form of stress cell
and the vast majority of both solid
tumors and hematological malignancies
express at least one of these nkg 2d
ligands
i think celiad as a company have done a
fantastic job
in developing the prototypic nkg2d
ligand
targeted car systems and they have
several clinical trials running in the
context of solid tumors
and hematological malignancies and to my
way of thinking
the the safety data that they have
generated to date is very encouraging
from the perspective of targeting nkg to
d ligands
so i would be very keen to evaluate
our mkg2d parallel car system in the
context of
uh refractory solid tumors which express
these ligands
thank you again dr reimers and dr mayor
do you have
any final comments for our audience
um no i think we had some very
interesting questions
uh and i would just like to thank
everybody for uh for joining our webinar
and have a good uh good day
and and could i just take the
opportunity to second that i'd like to
thank everybody for tuning in some
familiar and
participants and uh some um very
interesting questions
and i'd also like to express my thanks
to lumix for
for hosting this webinar
wonderful before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
ramirez and dr
mayor for their time today and their
important research
we'd also like to thank leopards and our
sponsor lumix for underwriting today's
educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand labs
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
that's all for now stay healthy stay
safe
until next time bye